from our standpoint there is no question
that this is a hate crime and the
anti-semitism should be called out
aggressively and promptly immediately
for what it is anything other than that
is a disservice to anti-semitism I'm
Jewish I'm the grandson of Holocaust
survivors who immigrated to this country
because it's a place of Tolerance and
like I said we need to be aggressive and
Cuong it out for what it is I know some
people will say that we should review
things and take our time but when you
look at the facts of what to inspire
yesterday it's difficult to argue
anything other than that we know that
they traveled over a mile deliberately
and slowly to this location we know that
they v passed many targets on the way we
know that they bypass targets
immediately near the store we know that
they took out long rifles across the
street after selecting this location and
coming here we know that they fired
aggressively into that place we know
that they posted favorable sentiment on
social media towards anti-semitic groups
so from my standpoint I want to be just
very very clear on how we feel here in
Jersey City and we want to be
transparent with our community on what's
happening we want to be quick lead
information and we want to tell them
what's happening because I think that
they deserve it and if they're gonna
trust us we need to be forthright with
information so I want to be clear on why
we called it a hate crime and what we
believe and why it points in that
direction and waiting the disservice to
anti-semitism the anti-semitic sentiment
is of the service that anti-semitism in
sense of not calling it out for what it
is we have several of the
representatives here who represent this
area on the City Council and they wanted
to talk a little bit about this
community because and I think as the
national attention to the shifted to
where Jersey City is today some of the
things get distorted this is a community
before I turn it over to them that has
no doubt face challenges but at the same
time has experienced historic drops in
crime over the last several years thanks
to great community partnerships hard
work of the police department and hard
work of the community and I don't want
that to get lost here this is a tragedy
for all of Jersey City and we're going
to work together to heal
you